what was it like having him on set snoop
dogg amazing
he was a presence right he just come in
and just calm and really first of all i
knew he was there because i had balls of
wine on my trailer when he was there so
i was like can snoop come every day
[Music]
welcome back to academy panels my name
is sean finney i'm super excited today
to talk to the women behind and in front
of the camera of day shift directed by
jj perry okay y'all day shift follows a
hard-working father who provides for his
eight-year-old daughter by using a pool
cleaning job as a front for his real gig
hunting and killing vampires this film
stars jamie foxx dave franco snoop dogg
and carla suzy
welcome everybody thank you welcome
okay so we've seen these vampire movies
you know what i'm saying but we we we
are seeing still that moviegoers love
this aspect and this culture of it
andrew i want to start with you what do
you think it is about vampire movies
that moviegoers still are fascinated by
after all this time they like the fangs
once those come out it's going to be
some you know action after that all the
stunt and flips and all that that's what
we want to see you know see that that
keeps the action going i love that
speaking of action and stunts and flips
lee this is a great point for you like
what do you what do you think it is i
mean i i think there's a thing with the
supernatural and with the mythos that
follows vampires that is still kind of
interesting they all have like a
background behind it but the fact that
they're supernatural super strong and i
think we've changed the rules with this
one yeah i mean it and this happens
mostly in the daytime which is uncalled
for yeah and it's a business as you're
gonna see you know fangs equal money and
so it's escapism it's fun
yeah i i i'm more with the lee here i
think there's like actually the deep i
mean i'm you know not to get into
theology of it
um but you know blood and the
representation of like what that is and
to take the life you know i mean it's
yeah i think there's there's really the
root of it is actually you know it
you're right there's so many vampire
movies how come a studio doesn't go
no like there's already enough vampire
movies and it's because the moviegoers
you know are very drawn to i think that
sort of more mythical you know we don't
get so much greek mythology but we do
get the zombies and the vampires and i
think that that's why you know people
sort of gravitate towards that because
it's you know the root of it is a little
bit more mysterious
[Music]
i literally was the first one to read
the script and i was just like i could
just see a play in my mind and when that
happens it's just like i know that
there's something there's magic here and
you know i you know you know worked with
my husband the producing partner on this
and we were like you know we developed
it with the writer and we just kept
building on the mythology and the lord
like that they were talking about and
then jj just just added that much more
and then chad sahelsky came out you know
just the whole team it was you know i
think we built something that no one's
ever seen before what's so dope i would
say about it is that there's so many
like comedic beats but also it's still
vampire so you still have to add that
horror beat in there too so talk to me
about just what it was balancing the
both of those i mean when we read the
script we were immediately drawn to it i
mean and we developed it with the writer
and we kept the heart of it so it was
always very grounded which i think is
important because that's the backbone
you know when the characters the
motivations they feel relatable you're
like oh i get them or i've been there
before and it just feels real but then
when you we heightened it with the with
the world the union the vampires you
know we raise the stakes then that
comedy really just pops from them being
in real danger and there are so many
organic moments like what was fun too is
we you know we'd have the actors you
know do the script and then we just
really have them improvised too and just
have fun and see what came out and there
was some magic in those moments too and
so just like that feel you know feeling
that adrenaline combined with that
laughter it's just like this visceral
experience and that's day shift
[Music]
what films helped you kind of center and
ground yourself as an actor as you
mentioned to get prepared you know for
this role yeah it was funny because you
know there's you know the plethora of
vampire movies is i mean it's there it's
entertaining and it was great you know
everything from the lost boys or even
only lovers left alive is that the title
with tilda swinton like i went down you
know every single path you know there's
art house films that are uh
you know that are really powerful but
had nothing to do with i guess the movie
that we were making but i obviously saw
you know i did my homework i saw them
the twilights
because they mentioned it in the film
and i hadn't seen any of that and it was
like oh my gosh and then i kind of had
to throw it away because that it wasn't
giving me an in because it is such a you
know um like new age it's a new age kind
of thing and so i was like how do i
ground it for myself and so i'm a mother
and you know you better bet and watching
these animals i said it earlier you know
before we presented the film jj was
showed me animals eating their prey and
i was like getting so fired up because
also protecting their prey so as a
mother like that was my way in and also
seeing this character as a businesswoman
right
she's trying to get her people
in the best place in the best land um
and it was land that was taken from her
so i could connect a lot to that being
mexican in california not knowing the
story lines but that really gave me a
lot of power to do that so for me it was
like i saw all of the vampire kind of
films but it was more the humanity of
her and her you know her need to claim
space that is what i connected to as a
woman but when it comes down to it is
like you know what's your motivation
your daughter's killed and you're trying
to get revenge and so like the way that
you got into that for me was more that
versus like as a vampire i can't wear
silver and i can't breathe and i can't
wink and i need to i can't i don't know
what to do with that you know so it was
more you know unlocking it and sort of
using that as like you know my homework
but not really the way that i that i
connected to the to the heart of of
audrey so that for me the lisp was so
hard so it was like i was talking like
this
yeah yeah i was like this and i was like
don't
you're going to suffer i was so bad it
was like i was like how are we and jamie
would be like i was like jamie don't do
that like it was so hard with the fangs
so and also i i draw drew blood because
they were very pointy and you can't
close so i drew blood a couple of times
on my on my lips because of it and then
i heard that um
okay this is i don't know what we called
it vamp one vamp two band three or
whatever the more the angrier she got
she had a different look right whether
it was the fangs and the t and the in
the eyes um having those contact lenses
is
i am in awe of any of the all all the
other actress actors have done vampires
and have you know series that do them
for a long time
i don't know how they do it it's like
you can't see in your periphery it's
very
wow it's yeah it's very limiting it's
like tunnel vision you can't really see
so it's hard to you know the eyes are
the windows to the soul so it's actually
really hard to
to emit with all of that stuff but the
fangs were and they were getting longer
as i was getting angrier anyway it was
all oh
it was a whole thing
we've seen some great specifically miss
alma hayek and from desto dawn really
kind of playing this and not that you're
building off for all legacy because
you're creating your own but tell me
about like the impact of being able to
see that representation as well and kind
of like what this means to you i mean
it's it's huge for you know
um
growing up in mexico and seeing uh salma
and not only you know knowing then lupe
velez in the 40s and you know how selma
is on her shoulders and then i'm on the
shoulders of salman it's literally you
know the generations continue but like
you said it's a legacy and um i love
that you know not only as an actress but
you know the storyline i loved about the
script was that you know i get to be the
bad guy
but now even i don't i don't i'm not
sexualized or objectified you know in
ways that latina women or women of color
tend to be
in certain you know genres or you know
uh when i was growing up that's all i
would see and so to see that we are
moving forward there's still a lot more
work to do but to see you know the way
that salma broke through
so many you know
so many barriers
and still doing so and so i'm forever
grateful because i wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for you know the salmas um and
the lupe velez and all of the la you
know rita moreno and all of the women
that came before us um and the fact that
they talk about it and they're not
afraid to talk about um all of those
challenges and all of the moments where
they felt tokenized or you know like
they had to play the stereotype you know
rita moreno talks about that too and
sometimes when that's the only job you
have you know you'll do damn well at it
you know and you'll play that stereotype
because it's going to feed your family
[Music]
he knows so much about movies and all
past and action and he's like i want to
see something new i want to see
something dope you know
and so he had this he was like we should
get contortionists in it we should use
it but he put on in so much effort
because he was very aware of with their
abilities what they need what like the
time they need and we would go to like
vegas and we went to a conference right
sorry they had like the top
contortionists yes and that's how we
found them you know tj was like we're
gonna put some of your flavors from your
breaking flavor and this and that and it
was just like i should break whistles
that's why her breaking flavor i'm just
translating forever sorry
but yeah it's like because my
backgrounds break down things so
he mentioned like yo let me get in there
like add your flavor in it we want to
show that these vampires can do what
people are used to vampires a certain
way so when we show that these guys come
from different backgrounds and they can
do all different kinds of things and
this guy has to figure out how am i
going to fight all these different types
in one area you know it's it i've i
definitely felt spoiled because it was
like it was kind of like
go be free do what you want to do and i
think another thing was that we got to
see you guys practice and really set
these scenes up months before oh yeah
like and just in these car you know
these warehouses with all these
cardboard boxes and seeing them do these
fight scenes it was us as producers we
were like oh my gosh this is looking so
amazing and then what else are they
gonna trust and every time it was just
like amped up and what's good as an
actor is that you're coming in and
you're seeing like oh i get to rehearse
and picture and visualize the scene you
know because sometimes it's just all
about the action or all about and the
way that it happened because we were all
you know in atlanta together it was like
we had the chance to go to rehearse and
so it really for me like i grew up an
athlete and i felt like such nostalgia
because they train like as a you know
like almost like a team of you know a
sport yeah and so it really you know it
really got us because we didn't have you
know rehearsal per se because there was
you know during covet and all of that
stuff so that is what really brought us
i think all of us together is the stunts
and and i would say on top of that the
one thing that i really like and
appreciate about jj and those guys is
they want the actors to do as much as
they can
and and you guys put in you guys will
like actively like yeah let's do it
let's get it everyone trains
and it looks so good i'm sorry no no it
was amazing but i was gonna say it looks
so good when you see you guys move and
it's you and it's not like
some hidden devil that it's like
obviously not them but when you see you
guys actually performing it and doing it
and just
it's not like
it's it's pretty satisfying to watch
[Music]
so i'm curious for you like when you
when you're approaching it from the hair
makeup space like how different is it
when you're thinking about that for
vampires that are walking in the day
right because we typically see them
low-light and kind of creepy so i'm
curious from your perspective as well
creating a look
and
you know putting the pieces together
went you know it it it played a big part
in
um
again with jj because he knew exactly
what he wanted
so once he transferred the language to
me
i took that and i said okay
this would be good for this because one
person was like six people she means
with the six people is that they're six
stunts per actor
i think people don't she meant that like
six different people are gonna be
playing one person so for hair and
makeup that was yeah yeah you know we
have the strong person the actor the
contortionist yes and then at what phase
yeah so it all varied you know as
they're transforming and becoming
full-fledged thank you andrew talk to me
a little bit more about this creating
the six different characters for one
talk about that process and who you're
actually who are those characters that
you're creating carla
the old woman that was fun because
she you know her head rolled off so we
had to do
the head by itself
her the contortionist and then
the stunt person it was like
you know it was six people in one and so
transferring that and making them all
look the exact same it you know that was
you know challenging
and to change the actors franco
changing him into his different looks
even his head um you know and just
you know creating the same cut the same
looks is is so for clarity it's it's you
for each individual actor you're also
creating the
same model for the contortionist for the
stunts person for and then the
individual head if their head got cut
off yes so you're every hair every
strand every makeup everything has to be
the exact same wow and of course we shot
the next day but we we shot an order
which was very helpful and that helped
me
because for continuity continuity and we
didn't flip flop back and forth which
was good
[Music]
the jamie foxx
we can't even i mean has been such a
pioneer in this industry for such a long
time and and continues to dominate and
probably dominating even more
now i'm just curious like does anyone
have any favorite jamie foxx um
experiences and stories i heard set was
pretty fun yo it was
it was kind of bad sometimes though
because there'd be we'd be laying on the
ground
like we're supposed to be dead
and and he's like cracking jokes and
you're like
wait wait oh so when you're when you're
actually he's like saying jokes in
between yeah like there'd be times like
orange
and you're like trying to sit there and
you're like you might be facing the
camera like oh my god i can't i can't
he tells stories too he tells stories he
gives you stories yeah yeah they're
amazing i mean i think every time he's
on all the time so i don't know how he
does it but he's like this fountain of
youth and energy yeah and i think like
we were saying like
right he'd come in like and every
morning it's like snoop would be coming
from one side with his music and he'd be
like popping with his music talking box
talk to me about the music because i
heard there was a song created i mean a
few there was a few i'm not joking a few
songs when i walked in there had already
been a song and he said don't worry
carla
you know i was like i don't know what's
going to happen so i said a line in the
film it was like um this is my valley
cabron drink him and i left and he's
like say it into my phone i was like
this is my valley cabron drink him and
he's like he goes to the side and he's
like this is my valley
and he starts going off and then sends
it to his friend
and i tell him like oh can you put some
like sauces down like i started like
noticing that he was doing it
i was co-producing because i was like oh
they already have like that one and i
was like let's make it you know
let's give it our touch and so he was
like oh yeah
and we were doing you know literally rio
de janeiro in like in a second he came
back the next day with the song like
fully i was just shocked at the the oh
yeah the amount of the creativity coming
out of him it constantly and instantly
and instantly like
it's just
and so he came back to set with the song
fully produced on his backpack had a
stereo would play it full blast so i was
scared the first day i was like i wonder
how my first day will be and you know
here i am like salsa dancing to like my
own song with my lyric that he just
created the next day and i now have a
new single that you can have
featuring jamie foxx yeah and how
quickly all of that happened and having
snoop dogg play
right it seems just like such a role you
know
so zen yeah and that was my question
like what was it like having him on set
snoop dogg amazing
he was a presence right he just come in
and just calm and really first of all i
knew he was there because i had balls of
wine on my trailer when he was there so
i was like can snoop come every day i
had you know he has his bottles of wine
and he has always like merch and he
would just gift us all his merch and his
record label t-shirts and i was like i
love snoop dogg he would
what was everybody's favorite present
from snoop yeah from seattle i mean the
jacket was pretty crazy
you guys jamie foxx does so great at
passing the baton like you know i could
see jj that was asking like what should
the last line of you know this moment be
and he he literally like jamie and him
said ask carla whatever carla says
i'm like
what like this huge budget netflix film
is giving
carl susan
i'm kidding like she's giving me the
ability to to have a say in the last
line of this you know of this character
and it was just so
empowering which is you know the
character i was doing like so they
really allowed me to feel that strength
in the training in the in the way that i
was dressed in the movie yeah i was felt
like i was being given permission to
take up that space
figuratively and you know emotionally
and physically and so i you know we were
doing an escapist like popcorn you know
fun movie but it has such more so much
more uh i think power in all these
stories that you're hearing that you
know the ways that we work and how we're
feeling like we're given that permission
and we're taking up the space as women
and so to go to a movie that is action
that used to be a lot of just a man's
world and now you're talking to you know
four women that felt empowered in this
process and that's pretty awesome i
think from you know netflix down to you
know jamie foxx and and jj and everyone
that was on the movie i think they
really wanted us to be able to have our
voice during the process of it
you